welcome to a new video against
grandmaster humacao overmuch god I'm not
quite sure how it is pronounced John GM
um he's not um yeah he only got this
what I'm getting at is he got only this
title only a couple of years ago at a
relatively old age like in his 40s and
seems that you can still make some
progress even though as an old-time ups
still some hope for me okay we have some
Sicilian night off turned into us
evening and variation and dad this is
certainly a normal position but i'm not
i'm not the biggest expert ever on this
what about now i only know these slides
with a for a bit but don't know that i
mean this is this is a theoretical
position i'm pretty sure but then how
exactly is this plate is this g6 on I
think g6 yeah g6 orders you play f5 okay
now then again then I can take you for
actually I think there's something like
this but
alright just straightforward yeah maybe
this is simply a like maybe I can I
cannot take maybe this is so in fact if
I'm not able to take now on you for then
all this is complete nonsense and if I
take on on Jionni forum it looks very
very dangerous 94-94 Bishop before I
have 6 i'm some also rather rather
tricky can I take with the bishop it
looks it looks terrible it takes on g6
we capture with the bishop this is
certainly crap okay so this looks like a
bit of an opening problem okay let's add
take him and see what happens if he
takes on g6 I must have must really take
with the bishop and this is hard to
believe yeah playing openings you don't
know against quite good opponents tricky
for the sake of variations I mean a
varying um and not playing the same
openings all over again I play all kinds
of stuff and very often I have
absolutely no idea only some rough idea
of how this is played because of some
classic games that are maybe studied or
some stuff that I saw in a magazine but
I don't really know it in any detail
yeah okay this is clear for what what
now a tape with the pawn he just takes
on f6 and then only form so i must take
with the bishop and here this looks very
very dangerous Bishop g5 acer is one
move
for starters which looks a rather tricky
but maybe just maybe I can play Queen d8
it's not not winning instantly yeah and
maybe I mean one thing I've got two
central pawns this is this is good okay
so he's double attacking on on f6 and if
i move the 90 plays 95 and win so pro
name Queenie edizioni move Queen age for
a queen edge for that's 95 for me the
only move that justifies this and it's
very lucky that this is working maybe
it's not working but at least there's a
move otherwise Knight a hair Queen to h4
would would win outright and turn if
this move is not working maybe maybe it
is not not all doom and gloom happy
spending time this is very very helpful
so that is not able to sort of blitz out
some aggressive move center yeah but
what am i doing next you have this kind
of this slow moves I was worried about
that so on Queen edge for there's still
this move okay what if I play king 2 2
h8 so on rook everyone that i can go
night to g8 yeah it's not like I'm
enthusiastic about others maybe rook c8
on look F 1 i've got rooks III and 94
hmm this looks like an active defense
let's play this I hope it is working
look everyone rooks III and I've got 94
walking a big fork on the Queen this is
a good news I think it's a good tactical
move that may be a that to me helps me
to defend I was threatening this anyway
this rook f2 really opened up this
possibility so if you place rook d1 or
rook f1 I just smash on c3 and play 90
for getting rid of pieces and maybe I'm
even winning material right now the same
my twin material sg5 is saying at the
end well this is tricky now what does he
play is going out of this but I can
still take if I take what is he doing 94
is still very strong I mean ff2 is
saying and g fiber saying so this is
working anyway Quincy 394 is very simple
Queen Hanks c2 hangs g5 hangs so I'm
winning material and BTW xc90 force also
winning it threatened night x f2 and on
35 so yeah this is this is over I don't
see move I thought this was very very
easy maybe it isn't okay it's good for
black but it's not not not to direct win
maybe okay but if i take here and now
now what about Queen B 6 for instance
Queen B 6 threatening i discovered check
this could be rather strong night h3s is
strong but it is not hanging it just
moves the king come on just take him
this is some a couple of extra pawns and
and simply a big position
what is this one extra porn okay I was
exaggerating but it's a big sin tired he
just doesn't have an attack so it's just
just excellent for black yeah i'm just a
504 come on now it wasn't i wasn't
really necessary to to allow there but
this also was are still not not much
going on
I can take you home okay the time yeah
yeah the time irritated me position was
a course called completely completely
one now I need to try on time it's still
not not even so clearing yeah at least
for blitz game yeah yeah yeah okay can I
you I could resign but I've got two or
three points or what I mean it wasn't
like completely over but okay I mean
this was was a complete win until I
allowed the edge corn so here I should
just play a non-move King h8 or
something and and it's over besides if
form might be winning also before takes
d3 check and then take on c2 maybe this
is the clearest yeah this is the
clearest minus 5 the computer gives ya
what's still an interesting game but I
was I was certainly in some trouble
until I found this rooks the eighth move
I think Luke's the head was was a good
good defensive move at least that looked
like this the computer as usual is
completely fearless night h5 with the
win but ok this isn't isn't bad right
Lucy 3 mm okay yeah thanks for watching